ja das ist ein spannendes urteil was uns
da gleich aus karlsruhe erreichen wird
dort begrüße ich den ard rechtsexperten
frank bräutigam guten tag herr bräutigam
guten tag aus karlsruhe grüße sehen ja
wir haben ja gerade helge braun den
damaligen kanzleramtsminister in dem
beitrag gesehen und die kanzlerin mit
ihrem o-ton damals in südafrika die
mündliche verhandlung ist ja schon jetzt
fast ein jahr her was hatten sie den
verein eindruck damals wir wird denn das
urteil ausfallen gibt schon eine tendenz
nein die gibt es nicht in der tat war
die verhandlung im juli letzten jahres
hier im gerichtssaal helge braun war da
auch präsent und vertreter der fdp also
der klagenden partei und der knackpunkt
in diesen fällen wenn es um äußerungen
von regierungsmitgliedern geht ist immer
in welcher rolle hat die bundeskanzlerin
der bundeskanzler eine ministerin ein
minister denn gesprochen also mit
amtlicher autorität in der rolle als
regierungsmitglied oder als
parteimitglied mit einer rein
politischen äußerung das ist nicht immer
ganz genau auseinanderzuhalten aber
darum wurde hier im gerichtssaal bei
dieser verhandlung dann gestritten und
die afg hat eben vertreten naja das war
ein staatsbesuch in südafrika und als
diese pressekonferenz zum staatsbesuch
dann begann sagte merkel eben aus
innenpolitischen gründen möchte sie eine
vorbemerkung machen aber das sei so die
afd trotzdem in ihrer rolle als
kanzlerin gewesen und da sei sie eben an
das neutralitätsgebot
gebunden und da haben die richterinnen
und richter auch sehr kritisch
nachgefragt hat sie da wirklich als
einfaches parteimitglied gesprochen
hätte sie das nicht deutlicher machen
können und der zweite punkt war dann
wenn sie als bundeskanzlerin dort
gesprochen hat gab es vielleicht gründe
dafür dass sie das durfte das wird im
beitrag gerade schon angesprochen
vielleicht um in der regierung innerhalb
der regierung die stabilität der eigenen
regierung durch so eine äußerung zu
befördern oder auch nach außen
außenpolitisch deutlich zu machen
wie sie stellung nimmt zur wahl in
thüringen also das waren so die fragen
wie hier im gerichtssaal gestellt wurden
und ja was die richterin unterricht dann
daraus machen das werden wir dann in
wenigen minuten erfahren die kanzlerin
sprach er davon dass das unverzeihlich
war wasser in thüringen geschehen ist es
ist ja nicht das erste mal dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht
regierungsmitglieder an ihre
neutralitätspflicht erinnern muss was
gab es denn da für prominente fälle in
der vergangenheit
ja das war schon öfter thema hier in
karlsruhe also es ging zum beispiel mal
um den damaligen bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer der hatte die partei fd
in einem interview als staats zersetzend
bezeichnet und das gericht hat gesagt ja
als parteipolitiker darf auch einem
minister weiter handelt er darf auch mal
so etwas sagen zugespitzt aber er hatte
das eben auf der homepage seines
ministeriums dieses interview auch
veröffentlicht und deswegen war auch
damals das nicht zulässig es gab
ähnliche fälle zur ministerin wanka oder
zur damaligen ministerin schwesig das
war immer so die linie dass das gericht
darauf achtet wenn politikerinnen
regierungsmitglieder die ressourcen
ihres amtes in anspruch nehmen quasi die
autorität ihres amtes dann müssen sie
eben die chancengleichheit der parteien
bewahren zu den abläufen gleich weil wir
auf 10 uhr zu laufen wenn die
richterinnen und richter gleich rein
kommen dann geht es erst mal um formalia
dann müssen die anträge die die afg
gestellt hatten noch mal vorgelesen
werden dann wären auch die anwesenheit
festgestellt wäre es im gerichtssaal da
und erst dann wenn die richterinnen und
richter aufstehen und in die vorsitzende
richterin sagte im namen des volkes dann
kommt das urteil und dann folgt so eine
kurze zusammenfassung der tragenden
gründe die wir uns dann gemeinsam
anhören das ist so das was
typischerweise hier dann um 10 uhr
beginnt wenn der saaldiener dieser
dienerin gleich die tür öffnet ja wir
haben ja auch das live bild vorliegen
herr bräutigam noch scheint das gericht
den saal nicht betreten zu haben deshalb
vielleicht noch eine frage bevor es
losgeht
dieses urteil jetzt ist der kanzlerin
merkel überhaupt nicht mehr im amt im
amt wird es trotzdem noch irgendwie
größere bedeutung haben
ja weil die grundsätze die hier
aufgestellt werden ja regierungen auch
überdauern und insofern an die regeln
die hier gelten wird sich auch die neue
regierung halb müssen jetzt geht es aber
los mit einem blick auf den gerichtssaal
unterscheiden wir jetzt hin der zweite
senat ist reingekommen
bitte nehmen sie platz
ich begrüße sie zum zur sitzung im
bundesverfassungsgericht den ein oder
anderen heute schon zum zweiten mal wir
haben ja gestern schon verhandelt
und heute eröffne ich die sitzung des
zweiten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur verkündung
einer entscheidung in den
organstreitverfahren
über den antrag festzustellen erstens
dass die antragsgegnerin durch die im
rahmen ihrer rede am 6 februar 2020 in
pretoria afrika getätigte aussage zitat
die wahl dieses ministerpräsidenten war
ein einzigartiger vorgang in der mit
einer grundüberzeugung gebrochen hat für
die cdu und auch für mich nämlich dass
keine mehrheiten mit hilfe der afg
gewonnen werden sollen da dies absehbar
war in der konstellation wie im dritten
wahlgang gewählt wurde muss man sagen
dass dieser vorgang unverzeihlich ist
und deshalb auch das ergebnis wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden muss zumindest
gilt für die cdu das sieht sie die eu
sich nicht an einer regierung unter dem
gewählten ministerpräsidenten beteiligen
darf es war ein schlechter tag für die
demokratie
zitat ende die antragstellerin in ihrem
recht auf chancengleichheit der parteien
aus artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1 des
grundgesetzes verletzt hat zweitens dass
die antragsgegnerin durch die
veröffentlichung des nachfolgende
abgebildeten textes wie eben verlesen
auf der website unter auf der website
der bundeskanzlerin und dann folgt die
lange website adresse
die antragstellerin in ihrem recht auf
chancengleichheit der parteien aus
artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1 des
grundgesetzes verletzt hat drittens dass
die bundesrepublik deutschland der
antragstellerin die notwendigen auslagen
zu erstatten hat antragstellerin bundes
partei alternative für deutschland
antragsgegnerin bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel aktenzeichen 2 bvl 4 aus 20
römische zweitens über den antrag
festzustellen erstens dass die
antragsgegnerin durch die
veröffentlichung des nachfolgend
abgebildeten textes dann wieder text wie
verlesen auf der website der
bundesregierung ist heute die lange
website adresse die antragstellerin in
ihrem recht auf chancengleichheit der
parteien aus artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1
des grundgesetzes verletzt hat zweitens
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland der
antragstellerin die note bedingt ausland
zu erstatten hat antragstellerin bundes
partei alternative für deutschland
antragsgegnerin die bundesregierung
vertreten durch den bundeskanzler olaf
scholz aktenzeichen 2 bvl fünf aus 20 so
viel zu den anträgen jetzt kommen wir
zur feststellung der anwesenheit
erschienen sind für die antragstellerin
herr abgeordnete des deutschen
bundestages timo kubala
unter abgeordneter der hamburgischen
bürgerschaft dr alexander wolf
als bevollmächtigter herr rechtsanwalt
dr christian konrad
für die bundesregierung aus dem
bundeskanzleramt vor
ministerialdirektorin dr babette geben
morgen aus dem bundesministerium des
innern und für heimat von
ministerialrätin dr michaela schulze
aus dem bundesministerium der justiz
ministerialrat dr thomas barth
sowie als bevollmächtigter herr
professor dr klaus ferdinand gärditz
dann wird folgendes urteil verkündet
im namen des volkes wird für recht
erkannt erstens die verfahren werden zur
gemeinsamen entscheidung verbundenen
zweiter die antragsgegnerin zu eins hat
durch die im rahmen einer
pressekonferenz mit dem präsidenten der
republik südafrika am 6 februar 2020 in
pretoria getätigte äußerung die äußerung
habe ich gerade verlesen die
antragstellerin in ihrem recht auf
chancengleichheit der parteien aus
artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1 des
grundgesetzes verletzt
drittens die antragsgegnerin zu eins und
zwei haben durch die veröffentlichung
der unter zweitens wiedergegebenen
äußerung unter der überschrift
pressekonferenz von bundeskanzlerin
merkel mit und dem präsidenten der
republik südafrika cyrill rama poser auf
den internetseiten der bundeskanzlerin
und der bundesregierung am 6 februar
2020 die antragstellerin in ihrem recht
auf chancengleichheit der parteien aus
artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1 des
grundgesetzes verletzt viertens die
anträge der antragstellerin auf
erstattung ihrer notwendigen auslagen
werden auch soweit ist sie die für
erledigt erklärten anträge auf erlass
einer einstweiligen anordnung betreffen
abgelehnt
bitte nehmen sie wieder platz
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren es
folgt jetzt von meiner seite eine kurze
zusammenfassung des urteils und unserer
entscheidungsgründe und dann wird das
urteil auszugsweise verlesen werden mit
dem heutigen urteil hat der zweite senat
entschieden dass der ehemals dass die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin dr angela
merkel durch eine im rahmen einer
pressekonferenz mit dem präsidenten
südafrikas getätigte äußerung zur
ministerpräsidentenwahl in thüringen und
deren anschließende veröffentlichung auf
amtlichen internetseiten die partei
alternative für deutschland afd in ihrem
recht auf chancengleichheit der parteien
aus artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1 verletzt
hat wie sie sich erinnern werden war
thomas kemmerich fdp am 5 februar 2020
im dritten wahlgang zum
ministerpräsidenten des freistaats
thüringen gewählt worden an der wahl
wurde wegen der angenommenen mitwirkung
von abgeordneten sowohl der afg als auch
der cdu
landtagsfraktion heftige öffentliche
kritik geübt die bundeskanzlerin äußerte
sich dazu am nächsten tag im rahmen
eines stehempfangs mit dem präsidenten
südafrikas dahingehend dass die
ministerpräsidentenwahl mit einer
grundüberzeugung gebrochen habe für die
cdu und auch für mich wonach mit der afg
keine mehrheiten gewonnen werden sollten
der vorgang sei unverzeihlich weshalb
das ergebnis rückgängig gemacht werden
müsse es sei ein schlechter tag für die
demokratie gewesen mit dieser in
amtlicher funktion getätigten äußerung
hat die damalige bundeskanzlerin die
antragstellerin in ihrem recht auf
gleichberechtigte teilhabe am prozess
der politischen willensbildung verletzt
der senat hat mit dieser entscheidung
seine rechtsprechung zu den äußerungen
befugnissen von regierungsmitgliedern
fortgeführt danach ist es um den prozess
der politischen willensbildung
offenzuhalten erforderlich dass
staatsorgane im politischen wettbewerb
der parteien neutralität wahren
für regierungsmitglieder bedeutet dies
dass sie wenn sie in wahrnehmung ihres
amtes handeln und dabei mit dem amt
verbundenen ressourcen in anspruch
nehmen den verfassungsrechtlich
garantierten grundsatz der
chancengleichheit der parteien beachten
müssen sie dürfen mit ihren äußerungen
nicht einseitig partei ergreifen und so
auf den politischen meinungskampf zu
gunsten oder zu lasten einer partei
einwirken
erfolgt eine solche äußerung unter
erkennbarer bezugnahme auf das
regierungsamt und die damit
einhergehende autorität oder setzt ein
regierungsmitglied mit dem minister am
verbundenen mittel und möglichkeiten ein
die den politischen wettbewerbern
verschlossen sind so verstößt dies gegen
den grundsatz der chancengleichheit der
parteien und die daraus abgeleitete
neutralitätspflicht
damit verletzt das regierungsmitglied
und dies ist der entscheidende grund für
dessen verpflichtung zur neutralität im
politischen wettbewerb die integrität
des freien und offenen prozess der
willensbildung vom volk zu den
staatsorganen der in einer
freiheitlichen demokratie unerlässlich
ist
das schließt nicht aus dass
regierungsmitglieder außerhalb ihrer
amtlichen funktionen am politischen
meinungskampf teilnehmen können es
bleibt ihnen unbenommen bei äußerungen
die in engen räumlichen oder zeitlichen
zusammenhang mit einer amtshandlung
stehen kenntlich zu machen dass sie sich
in ihrer eigenschaft als
parteimitglieder oder als privatperson
zu wort melden
für das amt des bundeskanzlers gilt dies
grundsätzlich in gleicher weise zwar
reichen seine äußerung befugnisse gegen
gegenständlich weiter als die eines
einzelnen auf sein ressort beschränken
minister jedoch ergeben sich daraus
keine anderen anforderungen an die
beachtung des neutralität und
sachlichkeitsgebot
allerdings gilt der grundsatz der
chancengleichheit der parteien nicht
schrankenlos
gründe die mitgliedern der
bundesregierung eine befugnis zum
eingriff in die chancengleichheit der
parteien verlangen müssen aber durch die
verfassung legitimiert und von einem
gewicht sein dass dem recht einer partei
auf gleichberechtigte teilhabe am
politischen wettbewerb die waage halten
kann
dabei ist jedenfalls den grundsätzen der
geeignetheit und erforderlichkeit der
äußerung zur erreichung der
verfassungsrechtlich legitimierten
zwecke rechnung zu tragen
die von der bundeskanzlerin angegeben
denn mit ihrer äußerung verfolgten
zwecke der schutz der handlungsfähigkeit
und stabilität der bundesregierung und
die erhaltung des ansehens der und des
vertrauens in die bundesrepublik
deutschland in der welt stellen solche
gleichwertigen verfassungshüter da
bei der verfolgung dieser zwecke kommt
dem bundeskanzler beziehungsweise der
bundeskanzlerin ein weiter
einschätzungsspielraum zu darüber hinaus
ist die bundesregierung nicht gehindert
sondern sogar verpflichtet für die
grundsätze und werte der verfassung
einzutreten und sich zum schutz der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
auch mit verfassungsfeindlichen parteien
zu befassen
nach diesen maßstäben sind die anträge
begründet die bundeskanzlerin hat die
streitgegenständliche äußerung in
amtlicher funktion getätigt die äußerung
fiel im ausschließlich amts bezogenen
rahmen einer regierungs pressekonferenz
zu gesprächen die sie in ihrem amt als
bundeskanzlerin bei einem staatsbesuch
in südafrika geführt hatte
weder der hinweis darauf eine
vorbemerkung aus innenpolitischen
gründen zu machen noch der inhalt der
äußerung lassen hinreichend klar
erkennen dass sich frau dr merkel nicht
in ihrer funktion als bundeskanzlerin
sondern ausschließlich als
parteipolitikerin äußern wollte an einer
dahingehenden klarstellung fehlte es
da die äußerung in einseitig partei
ergreifender weise negative
qualifizierungen der afg beinhaltet
stellt sie sich als eingriff in das
recht auf chancengleichheit der
antragstellerin im politischen
wettbewerb da dieser eingriff ist nicht
gerechtfertigt auch wenn bundeskanzler
und bundesregierung bei der verfolgung
der zwecke einer äußerung einen weiten
einschätzungsspielraum haben müssen
deren geeignetheit und erforderlichkeit
zur erreichung dieser zwecke zumindest
plausibel sein
die antragsgegnerin zu 1 hat aber nicht
plausibel dargelegt dass die
handlungsfähigkeit und stabilität der
bundesregierung tatsächlich betroffen
gewesen ist und den eingriff in das
recht aus artikel 21 absatz 1 satz 1
erforderlich gemacht hat gleiches gilt
für das von ihr geltend gemachte
außenpolitische anliegen dass die
ministerpräsidentenwahl in thüringen das
ansehen der oder das vertrauen in die
bundesrepublik deutschland in relevanten
die außenpolitische handlungsfähigkeit
einschränken dem umfang zu erschüttern
geeignet war ist nicht ersichtlich
dahingehende reaktionen ausländischer
staatsorgane sind nicht dargelegt worden
schließlich ist der eingriff in das
recht auf chancengleichheit der parteien
nicht durch die befugnis zur
informations und öffentlichkeitsarbeit
gerechtfertigt denn die bundeskanzlerin
hat das dabei zu beachtende
neutralitätsgebot verletzt
der äußerung kann auch nicht entnommen
werden dass sie zum schutz der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
verfassungsfeindlichen bestrebungen
erfolgt
die veröffentlichung der
streitgegenständlichen äußerung auf den
offiziellen internetseiten der
antragsgegnerin stellt weil
regierungsamtliche autorität in anspruch
genommen und auf amds bezogenen
ressourcen zurückgegriffen wurde eine
eigenständige verletzung des rechts der
antragstellerin da
die richterin war abenstein er hat ein
sondervotum abgegeben dass sie nach der
nun folgenden verlesung der gekürzten
urteilsgründe durch mich und den
berichterstatter auszugsweise verlesen
wird
aus dem gerichtssaal wieder zurückkommen
meine damen und herren das war die
kurzzusammenfassung des urteils die aber
die wesentlichen gründe schon mal auf
den punkt gebracht hat ich fasse das
noch mal zusammen den inhalt was wir
gerade gehört haben also das reine
ergebnis lautet bundeskanzlerin merkel
hat damals so das gericht die afd dpa
afd in ihrem recht auf chancengleichheit
verletzt das hat das gericht gerade
festgestellt die vorsitzende richterin
doris könig hat zunächst noch mal die
grundsätze die in so einem fall zur
anwendung kommen erklärt dass
regierungsmitglieder und auch eine
bundeskanzlerin dann wenn sie die
autorität ihres amtes und deren
ressourcen in anspruch nimmt dann strikt
an das gebot der chancengleichheit
und auch die neutralitätspflicht
gebunden ist und das hat diese
grundsätze hat sie dann auf den
konkreten fall angewandt auf diese
pressekonferenz bei einem staatsbesuch
in südafrika und dann hat sie
festgestellt dass diese äußerung in
amtlicher funktion erfolgt sei trotz
dieser vorbemerkung von frau merkel
damals eine vorbemerkung nun aus
innenpolitischen gründen zu machen sei
diese gesamte äußerung in amtlicher
funktion
erfolgt und habe so wie das dann
inhaltlich formuliert wurde die partei
fd in ihrem recht auf chancengleichheit
verletzt und das sei auch nicht
gerechtfertigt gewesen es wurde ja im
prozess ins spiel gebracht frau merkel
musste die stabilität der
bundesregierung sichern durch eine
öffentliche äußerung das habe sie
beziehungsweise ihre vertreter hier
nicht plausibel gemacht hat das gericht
gemacht und auch nach außen in die welt
zu signalisieren dass es in deutschland
stabilität gibt das sei hier nicht nötig
gewesen so sieht es zumindest das
gerecht gericht und auch die
veröffentlichung das ist der letzte
punkt auf der internetseite
das bundeskanzleramt ist dieser äußerung
die habe zwar in einem zweiten punkt die
rechte der afg verletzt das war so wie
groß der grobe inhalt dieser
entscheidung die wir gerade gehört haben
und ich bin wieder in kontakt mit bunten
ja also die richterin hat gesagt also
die kanzlerin hätte die
neutralitätspflicht verletzt und das
recht auf chancengleichheit verletzt sie
haben das jetzt ja gerade auch mal hier
bräutigam schön für uns erläutert aber
was heißt das jetzt für die zukunft
kanzlerin merkel ist ja nicht mehr am
abend wird es trotzdem das urteil
trotzdem in eine bedeutung haben müssen
die gerade die amtsträger ministerin und
beispielsweise der kanzler kanzler jetzt
in zukunft mit mehr trennschärfe
auftreten
also diese grundsätze die hier
aufgestellt wurden die sind ja nicht
ganz neu die gab es schon in früheren
urteilen zu äußerungen des ministers
seehofer einer ministerin schwesig
früher also die basis die abstrakte die
hat das gericht heute noch mal betont
und dann auf den fall von frau merkel in
südafrika angewandt das daraus kann man
aber auch schließen die gelten auch
weiter auch über neue
regierungsbildungen hinweg also es kann
ja mal wieder so eine situation
entstehen dass der aktuelle der
amtierende bundeskanzler das gefühl hat
sich zu einem politischen thema sehr
dringend äußern zu müssen und auch sehr
deutlich das kann ja auch immer sehr
schnell gehen und so wie das gericht
gerade diese maßstäbe nochmal
dargestellt hat ist es dann schwierig
bei einem offiziellen regierungs termin
etwas parteipolitisch ist ganz klar zu
äußern es sei denn das wurde da
ausdrücklich gesagt man macht das ganz
klar kenntlich also ich stelle mir das
praktisch sofort mit einer ganz klaren
vorrede passen sie auf ich äußere mich
jetzt klar als parteipolitiker und
nachher dann als bundeskanzler wie
praktisch oder wie praxisnah das ganze
dann ist da kann man bestimmt dann auch
streitig diskutieren denn das ist ja
nicht immer schwierig zu trennen weil
das gericht auch sagt natürlich dürfen
regierungsmitglieder sich auch politisch
äußern das sind politische menschen man
muss eben nur auf die trennung achten
aber ja das war ja ihre frage diese
grundsätze gelten auch weiter für eine
aktuelle und auch die künftige regierung
für künftige bundeskanzler noch mal
sehen wie sich das in der zukunft der
praxis auswirken wir zum schluss noch
herr bräute gaben gerade wurde von der
richterin ein sondervotum erwähnt was
hat es damit auf sich
ja das sind ist interessant im letzten
satz dieser zusammenfassung da sagte die
vorsitzende richterin könig dass die
bundesverfassungsrichterin astrid
wallrabenstein ein sondervotum
geschrieben habe dass sie am ende der
ganz langen urteilsverkündung die jetzt
noch läuft verlesen werde sondervotum
bedeutet das ist eine abweichende
meinung da sieht zumindest eine
richterin es anders vielleicht auch
mehrere aber zumindest haben wir gerade
gehört dass eine richterin das auch zu
papier gebracht hat
anders sehen kann nur heißen dass diese
äußerung von frau merkel in ordnung
gewesen sei es ist so bei der
entscheidungsfindung des
bundesverfassungsgericht da sitzen ja
acht personen in diesem senat und um
etwas für verfassungswidrig zu erklären
braucht man 55 stimmen zu drei dann das
ist das mindeste um etwas für
verfassungswidrig zu erklären
es zeigt aber das ist zwar eine mehrheit
im senat gab für dieses ergebnis das wir
gerade gesehen haben aber dass das wohl
umstritten war dass man auch argumente
für eine position finden kann dass diese
äußerungen von frau merkel eben nicht
gegen das grundgesetz verstoßen hat das
ist interessant weil sich so eine
rechtsprechung wir haben ja gerade
darüber gesprochen eben auch entwickelt
und es künftige fälle geben kann und
insofern ist das sicher wert nachher
genau zuzuhören und nach zu lesen denn
das ganze urteil wie das sondervotum
werden nachher auch der auf der homepage
des bundesverfassungsgerichts
veröffentlicht anders urteilt hast du
aus karlsruhe kam ich sage herzlichen
dank frank bräutigam für diese analysen
danke auch